orange juice what did you say orange
juice it's for one your feelings don't
you worry about Suzy eating enough
vitamin C many people reach straight for
the orange juice when they get a cold or
mix up one of these cold bus teen immune
boosting supplements packed full of
vitamin C it's supposed to help cure the
common cold there are growing 200
million dollar industry and
unsurprisingly their sales peak when the
cold and flu season does and with boxes
that claim that vitamin C helps support
your immune system why wouldn't you pop
a fizzy tablet when you start to feel a
bit stuffy but if you follow this little
asterisk you'll see that the claim isn't
supported by the FDA
that's because vitamin C doesn't cure
your cold you really crave orange juice
and that craving is your body wisdom by
what you just can't beat that great tape
you can trace the vitamin C craze back
to this guy Linus Pauling he was a
pretty big deal he won a Nobel Prize for
his work with quantum chemistry and a
Nobel Peace Prize in the 60s for his
anti nuclear weapon advocacy so when he
came out with a book in 1970 claiming
that vitamin C could help you avoid
colds and improve your health
it took off Americans clear drug store
shelves newspapers wrote that the sales
were not to be sneezed at and called it
the great cold rush but the medical
community was cold to Pauline's cold
claims for one they weren't based on any
actual science Pauline had personally
started taking vitamin C at the
suggestion of a friend and he got less
colds the criticism of course was that
just because it happened to him it
didn't make it a real study which
Pauline admitted to and asked that
someone actually do one but doctors
already knew that taking large amounts
of vitamin C wasn't the best idea
adults only need 75 to 90 milligrams of
vitamin C a day it's found in a ton of
different foods most people are eating
enough vitamin C in their normal diet
for a healthy immune system but
Pauline's book suggested taking 2,000
milligrams or more a day 22 times the
amount you really
need just because vitamin C is good for
you doesn't mean that taking more is
better for you a review of 46 different
scientific trials with more than 11,000
participants found that taking vitamin C
supplements regularly doesn't prevent
you from getting colds it can reduce the
length of your cold by a meager eight
percent less than half a day but taking
a supplement at the beginning of a cold
doesn't make it go away faster vitamin C
was found to be most useful for people
engaged in intense physical exercise
like marathon runners but for most
people routine supplementation is not
justified and taking extra vitamin C can
result in a classic too much of a good
thing that 2,000 milligrams Pauline
recommended is the amount in two
emergencies it's also the threshold of
how much you can take before you may
start to feel cramping or have diarrhea
or nausea it could get worse
a Swedish study found that men who took
just a thousand milligrams of vitamin C
a day or twice as likely to develop
kidney stones but that's about as bad as
it gets
the reason this hasn't been more highly
regulated is you can't seriously hurt
yourself at vitamin C no one has ever
died from an overdose Pauline himself
said he used to take up to 30,000
milligrams it probably gave him tummy
troubles but he was otherwise fine so
what will help your cold for one
hydration sure you can still have that
orange juice but just plain water or
clear broth will do the trick to things
like decongestants ibuprofen vapor rubs
they help ease the symptoms of a cold
but they don't necessarily shorten it
the best way to cure a cold is rest let
your immune system do its thing and
don't worry too much about vitamin C
you
you